in this course you'll go to the farm the
farm stack is fast api
react and graphql bec brace will teach
you how to use this stack to make a full
stack web app
hey what's going on guys this is big
brace i hope you're all doing well
welcome to the farmstack course in
today's course the technologies that
we're going to be using
are some of my favorite ones we're going
to work with fast api
react.js and mongodb which are the
components of the farm stack
and you probably have heard of this
suffix stack in other terms
like the mern stack which stands for
mongodb
express react node.js and what's meant
by stack simply is a set of technologies
that you can use together
to create a web application for instance
so farm stands for fast api
react and mongodb and we're going to
build our app using fast api for the
back-end server
react for the front-end client and
mongodb for the backend database server
so this is for data persistence and in
my opinion firm stack resembles the mean
stack or the merge stack even
the only difference is the fast api
because
react and mongodb are the same in the
three stacks
in mean we use angular and node.js and
in mern we use react
and node.js fast api of course is a
modern
and a fast web framework for building
apis
created by sebastian ramirez and this
uses
ascii and ascii stands for asynchronous
server gateway interface
and this is just the interface between
your application and the server
and the response time is lightning fast
and this is one of the big advantages of
having ascii server implementation on
your side
also fast api one of its biggest
features that it supports core routines
and concurrency without the need to
import the async io module in python
and in a way it's faster than express
which is node.js framework
and express is the e in the mean and
mern stacks as we said
so fast api also has interactive api
documentation
and it helps you testing the different
http requests like
get post put and delete visually using
open api which is itself based on json
schema
and i have a full crash course on fast
api you will find a card appearing now
if you're interested to check it out
react of course
is the most famous javascript front and
library for building user interfaces
especially spas or single page
applications
as per the stack overflow survey for
2020
react.js is just below jquery
so as you can read here that jquery is
still king
but is slowly losing ground to react.js
and angular
year over year as per the most loved
framework is just the second after
asp.net core
and the most wanted actually is react.js
the most wanted in the market and i will
leave the link to the surveys for stack
overflow in the description section
below if you would like to
check out other statistics very
interesting
you'll find here that the most dreaded
language is vba
and i've been working with vbe for some
time now at work
especially the debugging system it's
really awful
so no wonder that it's the most dreaded
language
all right following that objective c
pearl assembly
c php and so on so surprisingly
rust is the most loved language
i'm following that type script then
python but
actually the most wanted language on the
market is python followed by javascript
then by golang and i also have a react
tutorial for beginner backend developers
you will find a card appearing now check
it out if you like
last but not least we need data
persistence
so we'll be using mongodb which is the
letter m
in farm and i never did a tutorial on
mongodb on the channel
so this is the first one and i'll try to
be as much detailed as i can
and i've received a few requests to
create a crash course on mongodb
and mariadb so mongodb course is almost
ready and will be uploaded soon
mongodb is a nosql database management
system
and nosql stands for not only sql
and it's based on what we call the
document model or
collections of documents so if in the
normal sql system like mysql postgres or
oracle
if you have a table if you have first a
database that consists of different
tables
and each table has some rows and columns
here
in the nosql world you have a collection
of documents and a document is just a
file written in json format
and converted to bson or binary json
which is the zeros and ones for the
computer to compile and understand
so in sql world if you have a database
of different tables
and each table has a set of rows and
columns in mongodb
you have a database also but it consists
of collections
that consist of documents and each
document has different fields like
id name last name for instance
all these are fields in mongodb document
last word i would like to say about
mongodb that it was created in 2009
and it's the leading nosql system on the
market now
so enough me talking and let's go ahead
and start by creating our application
our application basically is a crud
application so the front end is going to
send http requests to the backend
the backend is going to fetch all the
data from the database in mongodb
the mongodb is going to send the data to
fast api to the back-end server
then the back-end server um using axios
technology
will send their response to the react
front end
which you will be seeing on the screen
so from front end to back end
then backhand to front end all right
you will need obviously to have python
installed you will need
also nodejs because we will need
npm in order to create our react
application
as far as mongodb you will need to have
an account on mongodb atlas so you
can click on start free and
you will feel the data here your company
how are using mongodb your email first
name last name and password
and once you do that you will have here
look included with your free cloud
database you will have
one free tier um to have a cluster of
computers with 512 megabytes of storage
okay it's just it's not physical
computer but
logical one so you'll have shared ram uh
you'll have 512 megabytes of storage
highly available replica sets end-to-end
encryption automated patches and rest
api
okay all of that is included in your
free tier
all right so once you log in you will
not find this
in clusters you will find a green button
in the middle telling you to create a
new cluster
okay so this is cluster zero this is
here how to connect
your collections and we said that
collections is the equivalent of tables
in sql world um you can
also have another cluster but i'm not
going to do it because you're allowed
only with one cluster i have my region
here in belgium
because i live in poland and i've
already tried the one in germany but
it was not so efficient so i created a
new one with belgium with
google cloud okay you will have
different options
so let me show you you will have google
cloud you will have azure
i used google cloud as you can see here
and i use the one you can see here that
free tier available
all right if you're in brazil in the us
in australia finland
all of these are free the ones only with
the free tier available tag
and once you know what you want to
choose you can click on it and create
free cluster
i can create another one because i
already have a free tier
a free cluster um and you can see here
that they charge you
for a second one for 0.44 dollars per
hour
all right um yeah but it's just pretty
straightforward
you will choose whatever and then you
will hit on create cluster
it will take some time to deploy and you
will be ready to go
how you can connect is by clicking on
connect and you will have different
tools
so you can connect to your application
you can use the [ __ ] shell which is
just a simple terminal to
interact with your database using
command line and
using the mongodb compass i highly
recommend that you
install the compass and the shell so
we're back to the mongodb homepage
you can go to software click on
community server
and you'll find here on premises all
right mongodb locally
so you have mongodb community server you
can download that
so mongodb offers both an enterprise and
community version of its powerful
distributed document database
so don't mind the enterprise just focus
on the community server
so you can download that it's um a
microsoft installer msi file
so this is the first thing you need to
do also you need to go to
developer tools and here you can
download the mongodb compass
and the mongodb shell okay so mongodb
compass
and you can click here on try it now and
it took you back to the tools
and you can download it here and the
same thing goes to
mongodb shell and if you're not sure how
to do that please let me know in the
comment section below and i will create
a quick video to show you how to set up
everything
in the path all right in the environment
variables so once everything is
installed properly
you can go ahead and type mongod
version and you will get this
db version 4.46 okay with this
json data okay the version get version
and so on also to access the mongodb
shell
you can go ahead and type [ __ ] sh
and you can take a look to the available
databases so you can say
show dbs and you will get the default
databases provided by mongodb
okay and let me show you the mongodb
compass so this is how it looks like
so in order to connect we can say [ __ ]
db
colon slash slash 127
point zero point zero point one or
localhost
on port 27017 click on connect
okay if you want to create a database
you can create that easily
let's say for instance we will have a
database with the name of sales
let's have a collection of employees for
instance
okay and create database
and immediately you have your sales
database created
and if you refresh here show dbs
you'll find that the sales has appeared
here so let's roll up our sleeves and
start by creating our backend server
with fast api
welcome back so the first thing that i
want to do is i want to create a folder
that will contain both backend and
front-end folders
so let's go to the desktop and
let's create a folder farm stack
underscore project
first we will care about the back-end
folder so
let's create that and let's open this
with visual
studio code all right great so
the first thing that i want to do here
is to create requirements.txt
and this is for the dependencies and
we'll need to have three dependencies so
the first one is fast api obviously so
fast api
with version 0.65.1
also i will need uv porn and
uv core is just a fast ascii server
implementation that
helps in the interaction between your
application that we're going to build
and the backend so this is the core of
fast api especially that fast api is an
asynchronous framework which heavily
depends on
synco8 syntax and therefore the use for
an ascii server
was essential so the version is 0.14.0
and also i will need motor and motor
is 2.4.0
motor actually is a full featured
non-blocking i o mongodb
driver so this works for python in
general
and it's working with fast api of course
in our case
and also works with tornado framework
tornado is
also an awesome asynchronous framework
and motor works with all kinds of async
i o applications as mongodb
driver so this is what motor does
all right so let's go ahead and activate
our virtual environment
i use ppnv if you don't have vpnv
installed you can install it via pip
install pip mv all right but i have it
already so i will not do that
um let's go ahead and activate that by
saying ppnv shell
alright great now we have our virtual
environment activated and the pip file
is created but still we will need to
install the dependencies so what we
gonna say
is ppnv install
dash r requirements dot txt
all right and hit enter
and let's close the requirements we
don't need that anymore
and i will need three files first is
main.pi
so main.pi i will need also
one for the database so we'll call it
database.pi
and the third one for the model just to
create our main to-do class
all right so let's go ahead and
start importing from fast
i want to import fast with a capital f
api all capitalized and also i want to
import something very important which is
called
course middleware so from
fast api.middleware dot
course all right i want to import course
middleware
and course stands for cross origin
resource sharing
i talked a lot about this in all our
django projects
course refers to this situation when
your front end client
which is running on the browser it has
naturally javascript code
this javascript code communicates with
your backend in our case
communicates with our fast api backend
server and in this case the back end
is in a different origin than the front
end
and origin simply is just the
combination of
protocol domain and port so you can see
here that the protocol can be either
http or https
domain for example our local host or
whatever
and the port might be any port so react
will have
for example port 3000 and our fast api
will have a port of 8
000. and we will need some sort of
permission
for the backhand to interact with a
different origin
a different port in this case so this is
what we're going to do
okay let me just close that and let's
just
instantiate on the fast api class by
creating an
object called app
okay so this is app object
and here i want to specify the origins
so in this case
um the localhost on port 3000 of react
and if you won't do this there will be
no connection between both
there will be no permission okay for the
headers the methods so we will need to
allow headers and methods
okay so in the origins this is
going to be a list with https
colon slash localhost column
3000 next thing that we want to do is we
want to take our app object
and we want to add the middleware add
middleware this one okay
so this method will take first of all
the course
middleware um course middleware
next i want to allow origins to be equal
to
the origins list um also the credentials
we will set it to true and i want to
allow methods we will set it to
everything or
star and also we want to allow headers
and let's just go ahead and create a
basic route so
app at app this is the creator dot
get method and just type slash this is
an empty route basically
we want to create a method or function
we'll call it read root
and we want to return something like
let's say ping pong
all right so let's check out first um if
the main page is working or not and in
order to run the server we'll say
uv corn main app and i want to
work on a reload mode so you don't have
to disconnect from the server and
reconnect again
in order to see the changes on the
application this happens
instantaneously once you refresh the
page
all right perfect so let's go ahead and
open that
and we get ping pong now the cool thing
about fast api that you can access this
documents it's called swagger swagger ui
and i've talked about this
many times in all my fast api projects
on the channel in the course
i have also another video um on fast
dpis introduction
and i showed everything in details about
the swagger ui
right so make sure to check that out all
right great so
this is good but this is useless to us
it's just to make sure that the server
is responding
so basically in a to do application we
need four main
um four main operations right the crowd
operation
so we need to read all to do's we'll
need to
post a to-do update and delete
and we can also get a to-do buy id if
you want a specific
do you can get it by its id all right so
let's work on that very quickly let me
just minimize this
for now and maximize this so let's have
another decorator
dot get and here we want to
access api slash to do
let's now work with the synchro 8 code
so we will define a method we will call
it
get to do and open close paren
column and for now we'll say return just
one
so i will need the same code basically
for um the to do by id so here i want to
have an input of
id all right so i need the to do
by this specific id and i will change
the method naturally so we can say get
to do is the same
by id and here i will
pass the id as a parameter or an input
i also want to post an id so it's the
same code as the get
but instead of get we will change that
to post
and here we'll say um post to do
and we will pass the input as to do
i want also to update and delete alright
so i will need two more
functions okay so let me just organize
this a little bit
so here i want to update the to do by
its id
so i will need to enter the id of the
to-do that i would like to
modify or edit and here i want to change
the method we'll say put to do
and instead of to do we want
the id because we want that id to change
and i want to change the actual data of
that
to do and last but not least
we want to delete add to do
okay so also to do by id
if we want to access a specific to-do
item
and we want to delete it so i need to
specify the id for that
and here i will change the method we'll
say delete
and instead of to do i want to delete
that to-do item with that specific id
um fast api object has no oh sorry
but there's no http request called
update there are get post put and delete
all right so we're good to go let's
actually take a look to what we have
let's refresh the page and boom we have
all the methods that we have created so
we have
get all to do's post at to do get to do
by id
put to do and delete to do all right
perfect so far so good now what i want
to do
is i want to go to module.pi
and i want to import from pedantic
and pedentic actually helps you to
auto-create your json schemas from the
model
so we're going to create a class now and
it works like an object relational
mapper
so it will take from the model and will
connect with our database that we're
going to create in a second
so we want to import base model class
then i want to create a class called to
do
with base model as a parameter
and i want two things only i want a
title which is a string
and i want a description
description which is also a string
and that's all what i need to do so
let's close model.pi
and let's work on our database now
so here what i want to do is to import
the to do class
from the model.pi so from model i want
to
import to do
and also i want to import the motor
module so import
motor dot motor underscore sync io
okay so this is the [ __ ] db
driver
all right and let me just open the
mongodb compass
so everything will be clear to you guys
but in the meantime i want to create a
client object
and this is going to be equal to motor
dot
motor underscore sync io and
i want to access the sync io modder
client
this one right here and this is
essentially for the connection between
the database.pi
and mongodb so we will need to pass
in a string [ __ ] db
colon slash slash
and local host colon
27017 which
is um the default port for mongodb as we
said before
um this is column all right so this is a
very important step
and we have our [ __ ] db compass
is ready but um we will leave it for now
let's continue let's actually create a
database i will call it just
a database and this is going to be equal
to
our client dot our database let's call
it
to do list and inside our database we
want to create
a collection so our collection
which is the same thing as a table
in sql so the collection is going to be
equal to
the database and we want to have a name
for the collection
let's call it just to do
all right so we have a database called
to-do list
and we have a collection which is called
to-do
all right great now let's go ahead and
work on our main functions
so the first function that i want to
create here is
to fetch one to do so we'll say a sync
def and i'm going to say fetch
one to do and it's going to take
the title as an input
and here the document is going to be
equal to
the collection dot find
one and i want to
specify the title to be equal to
whatever
title is going to be entered okay so
title is set to whatever title here
and here also i want to wait for that
all right and then i want to return that
document
okay so this is the first get so we want
to get
one to do um there is no doubt here
so in order to get one to do we get it
by title
and take a look to model this is the
title
or the id which is set in our function
in the main.pi file
okay so i hope that's clear for you guys
next i want to get all the to-do's so
we'll say
def fetch all
to do's and i don't want any parameters
and let's create a list of to-do's
and let's declare a variable called
cursor and cursor is going to be equal
to
the collection dot a method called
find and what we want to do essentially
is to loop
over any document in the cursor so
let's again use the async
keyword for document
in cursor i want to append in the
to-do's list
whatever to do with
any document
okay so this is basically the data that
i'm going to retrieve
and i want to return everything in that
collection
and finally i want to return all the
to-do's
all right so don't forget that this to
do is the main class that we have
defined in the model.pie
next thing that we want to do is to
create a to-do
so let's actually create a to-do
by defining create to do
function and here we want to take a
to-do as
the main parameter or main input
so the document is going to be equal to
the to do
and oops what did i do sync
then i want to declare a result variable
in order to await for the collection to
insert
that document in the collection so
let's wait for the collection
to insert one this is a method called
insert one and we will insert
whatever document that we're going to
create okay
whatever post or whatever to do item
that we're going to create and
also i want to return that document
next we want to update the to-do so a
sync
def and we will call it update to do
and this takes the title and
the description okay
both are set in the model class
in the in the model.pi in the to-do
class
okay and by the way if you're wondering
what's insert one method what's that
find as well these are mongodb
functions or methods okay so we are
writing mongodb
code actually inside our python file
so the motor module which is the mongodb
driver helps us to connect the
database.pi file with our mongodb
database
all right so let's get back to our code
so await
the collection to another mongodb
method called update1 so how mongodb
works when we want to update one item we
want to choose a specific item
and in order to do that we will need to
have a criteria so
which item do we want to update in this
case we want to choose by the title
so um the title
whatever title is set to and next i will
have the actual item that i want to
update so i want to use the set operator
by using the dollar sign
set this is inside
um double quotes and this is set to
whatever the description that i'm
choosing
and the actual description that i'm
updating so we will have
another set of curly braces and here i
want
the description that i have chosen
to update for the actual description
that i want to enter or update
all right i hope you guys following
then i want to render that document or
return that document
so i will
declare another variable called document
to
await the collection dot
find one with the title
that corresponds to that item that i
have updated
okay and we'll return that document
all right so this is the update to do
the last method
is to delete a to-do
so i'm going to call it remove
underscore to do
and it takes a title as a parameter so
um if we want to delete an item we
should enter the title first
and let's wait for the collection
to delete one which is another mongodb
method
and we'll set the title to be equal
whatever
is the title that we have entered
and we want to return a boolean value
and we'll set it to true all right great
so let's save that
and let's go ahead to main.pi in order
to
modify these functions that we have
created based on
these functions in the database file
right so this is 3000 the react.js port
i want to import also from fast api
http exception and this is just
for errors and exceptions so
actually this class what it does it
generates some exception information for
us
all right perfect then what i want to do
now
is to import from database
all the functions that we have created
so let's actually go to database.py
and let's take this from here
copy so this is the first one
all right so we have imported the
functions from database file
next what we want to do is to work on
these methods and let's start by the get
to do
in order to return just one we want to
have a response right so response is
going to be equal to
a weight for fetch all the to do's
which is there you go
all right one of those
functions that we have created in
database.pi
and you can see here that um this
actually returns a cool routine
all right and i've talked a lot about
core routines
concurrent code concurrency in general
um
in different videos before i will leave
all the links in the description below
you can check them out
so we want to fetch all the to-do's and
we want to return the response
the second function is to do by title
so we'll substitute the id with the
title
okay and we want the response model to
be equal to the to do class
so the response model
is equal to the to do class in our
model.pi file
and here also instead of id we want a
title
um let's have a response as well and our
response is going to be equal to fetch
want to do buy title
and don't forget the weight
and i want to handle exceptions so
i will say if the response if response
means if response is true
we don't have any errors then we will
return the response
otherwise we will raise an http
exception
and this is going to be 404 and the 404
is a status code for page not found
then what i want to say is
there is no to do
item with this title
all right let's actually make it nicer
so let's put a format string
and let's return that
title whatever title that we're trying
to retrieve
so let's move on to the next function
which is
posting a to-do i want also the response
model to be equal to the to-do
class and here i want to set the to-do
to be equal to the to-do class
and i want to take that to do take a
look here we have set the document to to
do
and we are going to insert a document in
the collection
so this is a json but we want to
convert that to a dictionary
in order to do that we will declare a
variable called
response and response
is going to be equal to the create to do
function that we have defined
and i will take the to do and i will
convert it to
dictionary and again i want some
exception handling so
respawns then we return the response
otherwise i want to
raise exception
and here we'll say we'll enter 400.
something went
wrong by the way 400 is the status code
for bad request
okay so you can type something went
wrong
or bad request
all right the next function that we want
to modify is
put to do so we want to
change the id by let's actually
change all ids by title
we will take the response model
also and we will set it to the to-do
class
and for the main function we want the
title
we will set it to string and also the
data we will set it to
string and data also we want to change
it to description or
desk um in the database in the update
function
you see here title and desk
so the response is going to be equal to
the update to the function and this
takes
the title and the description and also i
want some exception handling
so again um we can take
this one and we'll paste that here with
the same status code 404. and last but
not least we have the delete function
so let's remove that and let's have
a response as usual and we will take the
remove to do
remove to do function
and we'll remove the item by the title
if you remember here we have set the
title and also i want some exception
handling so
if response is returned is okay
we want to return a message saying
that successfully deleted
to do item otherwise
we want to raise exception we can take
this one
i'll paste it here and
that's basically it so we have the
delete the put
the post get
to do by the title by id and get all to
do's
all right cool we are pretty much done
with our database side
now let's go ahead and check out the
swagger ui or the fast api docs
and how we can connect it to the mongodb
database
and we'll see this interaction with the
mongodb compass
right so let's do it
all right so we have here our fast api
docs or the swagger ui where we can
interact with our database
and i have on the other side my [ __ ]
compass
is opened and let me show you
actually i was connected let me
disconnect for the moment and show you
what i did
so as i showed you at the beginning of
the tutorial you can
copy mongodb column slash
localhost all right
and connect
and boom you're connected and here you
have the to-do list that we have created
and this is because of the motor mongodb
driver so let's actually try that out
let's go ahead
and try to post a to-do
so let's say um to do
item one
and in the description let's say for
instance
walk the dog execute
right we didn't have any problems so
let's check that out here in the to-do
list
to do and boom we have to do item one
walk the dog all right uh
let's reset cancel let's close that
and let's check out here in the gut to
do so
try it out execute and we have the same
to do item one walk the dog
let's have another one for example posts
and let's say to do
um item two
and here let's say run
two kilometers all right
then let's execute okay
cool let's refresh here and boom
to do item two run two kilometers all
right so it's working perfectly our fast
api back-end server
is interacting with mongodb database
alright so let's delete um
to do it should be the same as in the
title so let's say that i want to delete
to do item two so to do item space two
execute all right successfully deleted
to do item
and if we were refresh it disappeared
all right so in the next part we're
going to move on to fleshing out the
front end with react.js
welcome back so as our back end is
working perfectly
and interacting with the mongodb server
we will now need to create our front-end
side and we will make it communicate
with the back end
so let's go ahead and create our react
app and i will use create react app cli
for that
but before we will need to go to desktop
and we will need to access farm
stack underscore project folder
all right and just to make sure uh
that we have only one folder which is
the back end and now we can use that
command
npx which stands for node package
execute
and i will use create react
app and for more information about
create react app please check out the
card that will appear right now
and this will take you to a react and
django video tutorial for back-end
developers
so there i talked a lot about create
react app what it is
and what it's doing for your project
following that the name of the project
or the name of the folder
so we will call it front-end and the
installation of the project is going to
take some time
so i will pause the video here and i
will be back when it's all done
all right cool so we have our front-end
project ready
in order to run it we need to cd
to front end or to change directory to
front-end folder then npm start
all right great so this is the default
react application
the development server is running on
port 3000 or listening on port 3000
just before we go on i need just to exit
the server
and we will need to install two things
the first
is axios so sending requests from the
client to the server
and getting the responses from the
server or the backend server to the
client
is the role of axios also we need
bootstrap so
boot strap and
yeah that's all oops what did i do um
npm install
axios bootstrap
all right cool so let's go ahead and
open that with
um visual studio code just
let's cd out
and open the whole folder with visual
studio code
by the way this js hint has been
bothering me for some time
if you have the same issue or if you
dealt with this
issue please let me know because i've
installed js hand globally
but um seems that
nothing happened really but i think it
won't affect our project so
let's ignore that for the moment and
let's go ahead and import
bootstrap slash
this slash css slash
bootstrap dot
min dot css all right
just to import bootstrap this is the
first thing we need to do in index.js
okay and that's pretty much it for
index.js
which is the main entry point for our
application in app.js we're going to
spend
most of the time um i want
to actually get rid of all that
and let's just type hello world
farm stack all right cool
let's delete the logo we don't need that
so you see even if you have here a red
line
yellow line uh it really doesn't affect
anything
it's just um it's annoying really
um if you happen to know the solution
for this please let me know in the
comment section below because
i really couldn't find a suitable
solution to solve this problem
so let's get rid of everything
um we will leave the app let me actually
delete all of that i will leave
the app this is the class name for the
app application
it has a class name of app so here we
will have
some just general settings so the text
align will leave it to the center
margin we'll give it zero padding we'll
set it to zero
and font family we will
use this one all right and that's all
so we'll close the app.css and let's go
ahead and work on the app file so
let's just delete that um or
we will leave it just we'll leave it
just for sanity check
so before we do anything we will need to
import react first
right so just make this bigger for you
guys
so we will import react
also we will need two functions use
state and use effect
from react
we also want to import axios from
axios and also we want to import the
bootstrap
so let's go here we'll import
bootstrap
let's first work on the visual side then
we will work on the logic
so let's go ahead and have a div
with class name
of app with list
group item these are bootstrap classes
also we want to justify content
center align items
center with a horizontal margin
set to auto so in order to add styling
to jsx
uh we will have double curly braces
and inside you can enter whatever style
that you want so i want to set the width
to 400 pixels and
also i want the background color to be
white
and the margin top to be 15 pixels and
inside that div
i will have a title with h1 tag we will
call it task manager
alright great so this has a class name
off card with text white
primary background which is the blue one
and margin bottom set to one
below the task manager i want to add h6
tag
with three words fast api react a
mongodb
then i will have another div with the
class name of card body
inside that main div i want to have an
h5 tag
with a class name of card and i will say
add your task
this has a dark background with margin
bottom three
and the text is white to have the
contrast the next thing that i want to
do is to create two input fields
one for the title and the other one for
the description
and a button this button is to add your
task
so in order to do that i will wrap
everything around
a span this pen will have a class name
of card text
so this is the first input and this is
the second input for the description
so both they have mb2 or margin bottom 2
with form control with different names
title
in and des in and both they have
placeholders so one with title and the
other one with description
the next element in our application is
the add task button
so it has a class name of btn with btn
outline primary
alright so i've given it a border radius
with 50 pixels to give it that rounded
shape around the button and also set the
font weight to bold
and this is everything inside the span
so the idea here
is when you will enter the title and the
description
and you will add the task the task will
appear below here
with one button only which is the delete
below this pane
and on the same line with the add your
task
h5 tag i want to add another
h5 tag with your tasks let's actually
give the button
some margin bottom in order to have some
space
so mb will set it to 2 that's better
and then what we want to do is to
display all of your to-do's below
your tasks all right so let's have a div
inside that div we should plug all of
our to-do
items and this should be an external
component and down here below i want to
create a copyright mark
and you're free to change the colors if
you want of course this has a background
of warning which is the yellow one
right with a class of card
text dark bg warning padding
y on the vertical axis with one
and margin bottom of zero just don't
forget to delete that div below
and that one because i've written it
again
okay so it's the same thing
once we save nothing will change all
right so before we move on and create
our components folder with the different
components
there are a couple of things that we
need to do in our function
the first thing we need to do is to
create different variables
one for the to-do list one for the title
and another one for the description and
all of them will be set to use date
so set to do list will be set to you
state
with an array of empty object and inside
here we will append
items each time you will add a task also
we will set the title
and we'll use the state for just
anti-string
nothing for the moment the same thing
goes for the description
and once you add a title and description
hit add task
everything here will change so this is
the usefulness of use state function
the next thing we want to do is to read
all the to do's
for that i will use use effect
method and we'll use use effect in order
to accept the http request methods
like get post and so on so the first
thing we want to do is to
read all of the to do's and this what
we'll do is that it will send a get
request to the fast api backend server
okay then this callback will return a
promise and we handle promises with dot
then
and having a response as an input we
should access all the data inside that
input or the response all right
and all of that is wrapped inside the
set to-do list that we have defined here
above
and the last thing we need here is to
post a to-do to add a task actually when
we click on the add task button
so this ad2do handler variable which is
set to a callback function
which doesn't take anything as an input
returns
that post request so the first parameter
is the origin
so http localhost port 8000 for the api
and to do
and we want to display the title for
whatever title it is
and the same for the description and
then we have a callback as a response
that goes for the response as an input
and we can console.log
press or we can just alert res
this is just for verification step now
we will need to update both input fields
and the add task button all right
so the first input field which concerns
the title
we will update it with the onchange
attribute
this takes an event as a parameter then
it returns
set title which we have set here above
and inside the set title we have a
parameter of event.target.value
same exact thing goes for input so
input also we will have unchanged
attribute
with an event that set the description
for event.target.value
last but not least we have the button so
for the button we have add to do handler
function here
so the button should be updated in order
to reflect the changes
that will occur when we click on the
button
and don't forget to re-add the margin
bottom three
in order to push the your tasks a little
bit below
so this is pretty much everything that
we need to do for app.js
the last thing that we need to do is to
add the to-do
items inside both div tags so let's go
ahead to our source folder
and let's create a folder called
components
and inside components i will create a
file i will call it todo.js
and another file called to do
listview.js to do
list view.js
first of all let's go to to-do and let's
import
axios and react now i want to create a
to-do item function that it will take
as a parameter props inside that
function
i will declare a variable called delete
to do handler
and i will set this to a callback
function that takes title
as a parameter in order to delete
whatever to do
item that we want to specify by the
title
and what we want to return actually is
the item itself
and next to that item we will have a
delete button
so you can see here we have a div with a
paragraph
span with the style and we will enter
or we will plug the props.to do dot
title
so the title first and this is going to
be bold
then a column and then we want to have
the description next to it
and then after we will have a button
with on click attribute
is going to be set to a callback
function which doesn't take anything
as a parameter and it will return the
delete to do handler function that we
have
created above here again it will take
props.to do
the title and why is that because we
want to
search that item in function of title
so the main criteria for deletion is the
title
also we'll have a class name with a
button and all of that
is again bootstrap classes so now we
have
our to-do.js ready we want to import
that
in the to-do list views.js but before we
do that we need first to
export the to-do item function
all right in order to import it in the
to-do list view.js
so we will import the to-do item from
current directory where is the to-do.js
all right and then i will need the
function that i'm going to plug
inside my app.js here so
all the items that will appear below
should be created in our
to-do listview.js so let's go ahead and
create that function
we'll call it to do view and it takes
props as a parameter
and what it will return simply um ul
or unordered list and the props.to do
list dot map which is one of the array
methods like reduce
filter and sort and we're going to map
whatever to do
and plug it inside that to do item so
that to do item that we have
imported from the to do.js here
all right so this is how it's working
and let's not forget to export it
so in order to test everything together
let's go ahead and open our back-end
server
so we'll go to back-end
and uv-corn main app
load
okay good so it's listening on port 8000
so
if we will refresh the page
okay cool i'll just make this a little
bit bigger
there is something very important that
we forgot to do is to
import the to-do view from the to-do
list
all right so we'll need to do that below
the bootstrap
and now instead of that comment we will
add our actual to-do
item all right perfect so we have our
front end
running on that instance of the terminal
and we will need also to
open a new terminal instance
for the back end so uvicorn
main app
reload
okay great so let's open our fast api
swagger alright so
for the moment our database doesn't hold
any data so this collection has no data
as you can see here in the mongodb
report
um on this side we have our backend
server our fast api
server this is the react application our
client and here we have our database
server our mongodb database server
so let's try to add a to-do item
so we'll say to do one
study rust language
add task ambu to do one study
rust language all right and if we
refresh here
we will have this document created in
our database so we'll have an
id which is very similar to the primary
key in the sql world
this is auto generated by mongodb we'll
have our title and description
right let's try to add another one to do
two
run 10 kilometers add task
refresh the same
sleep at 9 00
pm at task
refresh and so on
so you can see what's happening if we'll
delete let's say
um to do two delete it from here
refresh it will disappear let's add
another one so let's say to do
four
sketching at task so it adds below
and if you will go to the back end you
will find the same information
so let's try to access actually
api slash to do
and you will find all of our to-do's
all right everything here similarly in
the docs
when you will hit when you will click on
get to do
try it now or try it out execute
you will find your to-do's this
json format all right and let's refresh
that as well
so to be identical okay so this was an
introduction to the farm stack and how
we can work with the three technologies
if you like the video please like it
share and subscribe to the channel
and i appreciate your support guys thank
you very much if you have any questions
please let me know in the comment
section below
take it easy